are you working to scale your quantum  diagnostic technologies for a clinical  setting and if so what diagnostic  technologies can we expect to see in the  future from your work yeah so quantum  diagnostic technologies have unique  potential to make an impact in the  clinic because of the ability for many  clinical sites many clinical labs to  adopt the technologies without new  infrastructure and so we're expecting to  see these technologies be incorporated  in molecular diagnostics and include  immunoassays down to you individual  protein molecules single single protein  molecules of digital amino acids and  looking for individual nucleic acids so  down down to single nucleic acids which  would be digital nucleic acid assays so  those types of assays are going to be  beneficial across a range of clinical  Diagnostics from in fields in cancer  neurodegenerative these  neurodegenerative diseases and  cardiovascular diseases for example